welcome to this video playing dead man
walking one of them play i said that i
never played before if you can believe
the statistics Queens gambit okay
classical with Bishop Isom then always
play Bishop f4 it never played Bishop g5
much yeah this line I had studied very
long time ago and I must admit that I
have forgotten most of it um yeah this
is one thing that I can still remember
check like I needed to attend to this
threat he completely ignored it mmm yeah
why just a pawn up oh he wants to trade
Queens um interesting yeah probably
hoping for opposite colored bishops okay
yeah I wonder what the right piece set
up is here night-night to deform and the
bishop to c3 somehow not sure can also
put the bishop on deform so he wants to
exchange the night hmm
yeah it's not really ideal okay maybe I
can play with the bishop on c5 setting
up this this type of blockade hmm maybe
look here bishop on c3 or something yeah
it's very difficult to do something and
then game him maybe I can play with with
F 3g for each form it also has the King
March to d6 I have Bishop before them
okay maybe start with this why don't my
dad this is a very safe set up now
I want to go G for King to f4 and
impossibly g5 at the right moment
a g6 will lose both pawn some not really
a problem okay um g5 forever maybe L
intending g6 check and now I can can use
the f porn as well foxy 45 no that's
quite ok it's this rook c4 is not or
something is not leading to anything I
just have a five now and age 6 yeah this
looks looks very very good check rook
age seven
check I give the check here again then
or king of six King f6 threatening rook
age a teammate but wait what wait f6
rook g-form look G [ __ ] edge five I'm
threatening f7 and we should be four
there's no defense to that I don't see
one check f7b should be form promotes
the pawn
now no defense there should be six less
f7 or ruki seven assists simplest time
morning channel no defense black resigns
yeah yeah you can blonde at this this
poem with this tricky in the planning
and check after that of course black is
in in some some trouble check you can
still fight in this end game of course
especially after I allowed the night
trade it since of course also better
after the nitrate for white button he's
getting somewhat closer to the opposite
colored bishops endgame I have a very
nice bishop on c3 for here it's clear
that after that I go h 4 and so on
gaining space and not not quite sure
when the point arrives where it is
really not possible to hold it now this
is already very bad for like I mean I
also have fyf fire for this is starting
with this I went I went like this check
and I don't really think that black can
I would this it looks looks very
overwhelming here i'm winning definitely
but i'm not quite sure what black should
do to defend it pushing up to f5 from
gets gets very very problematic also if
I once mmm on f5 Bishop is going back i
also have ideas like King f4 root g one
switching the check or King f45 entering
the position b5 and d 5 additional
weaknesses I don't think black can about
this when this was definitely definitely
leaning
check f6 is just promoting the pawn not
much to do okay thanks for watching